hi I'm Erik Bosse and Dirk Phoenix ends
the x-men film series as we've known it
for these past two decades and it's
occasionally brilliant often confusing
glory with you Jackman Wolverine as the
one constant looking super confused as
everyone around him keeps getting recast
three-strikers
yeah I'm out Dark Phoenix is set in 1992
presumably bringing the unbelievably
complex and self-contradictory x-men
timeline full circle with the first
x-men of 2000 in which several
characters aged 30 years in the span of
eight years but now that this series has
concluded officially allow me to explain
start to finish the full complete x-men
Cinematic Universe timeline because it
is wild ruler warning if you haven't
seen any of these movies yet but to be
honest at this point you probably won't
care let's start with the first x-men
released in the year 2000 which is
technically set in the not-too-distant
future so let's say late 2000 rogue Anna
Paquin Wolverine Hugh Jackman joined
storm Halle Berry Cyclops James Marsden
Jean Grey famke janssen and Charles
Xavier Patrick Stewart against magneto
in McKellen mystique Rebecca romaine
sabertooths Tyler mane and toad ray park
aka Darth Maul then there's x2x been
united in 2003 it added Nightcrawler
Alan [ __ ] an amazing opening scene
where he tries to assassinate the
president there's also Iceman Shawn
Ashmore pyro Aaron Stanford and a brief
cameo by Colossus and Colonel Stryker
Brian Cox the story ends with Jean Grey
sacrificing herself to save the others
now these first two x-men movies were
pretty great they launched the careers
of Hugh Jackman and Kevin Feige
who was an associate producer on the
first one really they set the standard
of Hollywood's superhero adaptations but
the third movie hit a roadblock
it was x-men The Last Stand and 2006
directed by Brett Ratner and co-written
by Dark Phoenix director Simon Kinberg
they attempted to adapt the famous Dark
Phoenix storyline from the comics but
the movie that the studio ended up
releasing ended up downplaying that
story in favor of a mutant cure
storyline had added angel Ben Foster
Hank McCoy beast Kelsey Grammer Kitty
Pryde Ellen Page and juggernaut Vinnie
Jones of the jungle [ __ ] and a ton of
other mutant cameos most of which we
have forgotten this story killed off
Cyclops Charles Xavier and Phoenix
magneto lost his
powers but the final shine applied he's
still kind of had them so now and
Charles Xavier seemed to resurrect in
the body of an awakening coma patient
yeah so at this point Fox Studios
pivoted with a new x-men origin series a
series that than they've just been one
movie and they were gonna start with the
most popular character from this
franchise Wolverine the story tracked
Logan's ageless life his birth is James
Howlett in 1845 his fighting in the
american civil war in the 1860s world
war 1 in 1917 1918 World War 2 in the
1940s in the war in Vietnam in the 1970s
Logan joins Colonel Stryker who's now
played by Danny Huston and a team
including Sabretooth Liev Schreiber
gambit Taylor Kitsch and Wade Wilson
Ryan Reynolds but a really bad early
version of Deadpool that the Deadpool
did you probably know makes fun of a lot
and these main events are set in the
late 70s early 80s that kind of time
period this movie ends with Charles
Xavier ad aged Patrick Stewart now
walking on his feet saving a young Scott
Summers and other mutants from strikers
lab Professor X randomly showing up with
that jean-luc Picard charm it's kind of
the well that these movies dip back into
over and over kind of like oh don't
worry papa X is back everything's going
to be okay and I will make it so that's
wrong franchise so the x-men franchise
was kind of in a weird place here until
Matthew Vaughn essentially rebooted it
with x-men first class which came out in
2011 now this movie opened by revisiting
the opening of the first x-men showing a
young magneto at Auschwitz in 1944 and
this movie showed him aged up into adult
magneto played by Michael Fassbender
Nazis in the 1960s he meets Charles
Xavier played by James McAvoy Hank McCoy
is now Nicholas Hoult and mystique is
now Jennifer Lawrence who at one point
shape-shifts into an older version of
herself played by Rebecca Romain okay
these x-men get involved in the acute
Missile Crisis and Magneto pushes in
Nancy Coyne
they're Kevin Bacon's head it's pretty
sick there are other mutants of this
movie including havoc and Emma Frost
played by January Jones here despite
appearing younger and x-men origins
which was set 20 years or so later and
there's a cameo by Wolverine who
delivers some of his best life he's me
in America mentions Xavier self first
class establishes the origin of Charles
paralysis as a deflected bullet hits him
in the spine which actually retcon
professor axe walking at the end of
x-men origins now later on Days of
Future past also kind of establishes
Charles's ability to walk in the 70s
time period but they explained that that
was because of a serum that allowed him
to walk by inhibiting his telekinetic
powers which is powers that he still
uses in x-men origins so yeah it doesn't
make sense because it's a retcon anyway
two years after first class came out in
2013 James Mangold made the Wolverine
with Hugh Jackman on a present-day solo
mission in Japan this movie was also
really well received by critics and
audiences although it ended with once
again Patrick Stewart Charles Xavier
showing up along with Ian McKellen
magneto meeting Logan at the airport's
say in something like Logan we need your
help neither of us can remember how the
last stand ended Charles is joking we
don't give a [ __ ] now in that scene
Logan saw an ad for Trask industries
robotics setting up the apocalyptic
future the next film x-men Days of
Future past which made a surprisingly
good attempt at reconciling the
different x-men timelines with time
travel of the mind it begins in the
apocalyptic future of 2023 featuring all
the old-school generation actors
Professor X Magneto Wolverine rogue
storm Kitty Pryde Iceman and then they
added blink bishop and a few others
Kitty has developed the ability to
displace people's consciousnesses back
in time to warn themselves about coming
sentinels hunting them so they decided
to do this to Wolverine the ageless
mutant who was alive in 1973 dear that
the Sentinels program was introduced by
Bolivar Trask Peter Dinklage in the year
that mystique assassinated him setting
these events and emotions so Logan jumps
back in time to his earlier self meeting
all the first-class versions of the
x-men including Charles Magneto and
mystique and they're joined by newcomer
Quicksilver played by Evan Peters in
this movie they fix all the events in
the past and they reset the timeline
with Logan's consciousness returning to
an altered future sometime in the 2000s
with Marsden Cyclops
Janssen Jean Stewart Xavier and grammar'
beast they're all hanging out having a
good time meanwhile bogans body in the
1970s was left with a younger striker
William Hellman this time home and a
weird twist was hinted at to be mystique
in disguise and they never did anything
with that don't ask but the good news is
that this movie erased the events of
x-men
origins and x-men The Last Stand so
great and the studio announced that the
next x-men movies would follow the first
class and Days of Future past timelines
telling a news story in each decade and
the first one of those was x-men
apocalypse set in the year 1983 with the
villain apocalypse blue Oscar Isaac
nearly destroying the world with new
younger x-men introduced including
sophie Turner as Jean Grey ty Sheridan -
Scott Summers Kodi smit-mcphee as
Nightcrawler Alexandra Shipp as storm
and Olivia Munn as Psylocke
there's also a younger version of Angel
a number of others but there were some
problems in this movie so Jeanne already
being a teenager at Xavier school is
another retcon like The Last Stand
prologue show daddy age Stuart D H
McKellen in 1986 Co recruiting Gina's a
girl but that retcon was okay the more
confusing one was Jean using the Phoenix
force to defeat apocalypse something
that we don't see her acquire until Dark
Phoenix 10 years later
apocalypse also features Jean briefly
running into Wolverine shortly after his
adamantium surgery in alkali lake lab
setting them free it's actually pretty
great scene the movie also features
Jubilee as a teenager despite her
appearing as a teenager in a deleted
scene in x2 movie also features Caliban
despite a different version of him
showing up in Logan and the movie ends
in a post-credits scene setting up mr.
sinister that never really went anywhere
yeah fans were kind of mixed on x-men
apocalypse so the studio just kind of
put a pause on that part of the timeline
meanwhile that old rogue James Mangold
released another film Logan and Logan
probably should have been the final
x-men film
it's another standalone Wolverine story
in the style of the Wolverine and it's
set in 2029 presumably in that revised
future after Days of Future past except
things are still apocalyptic because
every future is apocalyptic mutants are
nearly extinct due to anti-mutant toxins
and food and Charles accidentally
killing most of the x-men in a
telepathic seizure also mutants have
become these legendary folk figures
mythologized in x-men comic books that
meta Lee look exactly like actual x-men
comic books in our world Charles and
Logan died tragically in this movie but
they help a younger generation of mutant
kids escape to Canada
it ends in a beautiful closing image of
Logan's spiritual successor taking the
cross that is grave and turning it into
an X and that's how it all should have
ended but I should point out that during
these years there were also two really
Deadpool movies technically part of the
x-men universe with new versions of
Colossus juggernaut there are other
mutants but really it's all in a more
meta Looney Toons kind of way like
Deadpool jokes about McAvoy and Stewart
timelines and Deadpool - there's a cameo
from the x-men apocalypse era mutants
doesn't make sense because that wasn't
the 80s not the present-day but whatever
Louise dooms and Deadpool - ends with
them going back in time to the 80s to
kill the version of Wade Wilson from
x-men origins another x-men stories
seemingly set outside of the main
timeline is legion which is co-produced
by Simon Kinberg it's on FX if I was
David Haller
son of Charles Xavier in a conflict with
Amahl Farouk Shadow King the show is
nuts and it seems to be set in the
future after Charles's death but the
production design also suggests it could
be a 60s time period who knows it seems
pretty removed from time and that brings
us to Dark Phoenix which the studio
intended to follow the first class Days
of Future past apocalypse timeline and
redo the Phoenix story from The Last
Stand it's set in 1992 which yeah it's
confusing for two reasons at least one
this is only eight years away from the
first x-men suggesting that in that span
of time James McAvoy is going to age
into Patrick Stewart Michael Fassbender
is gonna age it to Ian McKellen Jennifer
Lawrence is gonna age into Rebecca
Romain and Nicholas Hoult is gonna age
into Fraser and yeah there's also Jean
Cyclops storm and Nightcrawler agent
into their older cells but you know fair
enough their recent reboots they could
age into any new version of themselves
but secondly and this is never explained
in these movies those first four were
all in Cuba in 1962 in x-men first class
and thirty years later in 1992 none of
them have aged at all Charles has lost
his hair in the 80s in the Apocalypse
story but they're all still fairly young
and Dark Phoenix it's as if they took
Logan's agelessness which was the aspect
that made him uniquely suited for the
mission in Days of Future past and
decided that all the x-men have it -
essentially these x-men movies went from
working their asses off to fix
continuity in Days of Future past - not
at all giving a [ __ ] about continuity in
Apocalypse and Dark Phoenix so why did
this happen some say that Bryan Singer
who directed the first two x-men and
then returned for Days of Future past
and apocalypse was problematic for a
number of reasons including a tendency
to disappear from set and workhorses
like Simon Kinberg had to step in and
clean up the messes the best he could
ken Burke always wanted to
tell the dark phoenix story as it was
meant to be told but unfortunately he
took the reins right as fox sold all of
its assets to disney do mean the future
of this x-men franchise because studio
execs assume that Disney's Marvel
Studios will just reboot them all so the
Fox execs divested themselves from
marketing Dark Phoenix properly allowing
it to get delayed again and again so
that over two years later when Papa X
goofily freezes everyone in these movies
audience just like us are like oh right
that's a thing in these movies I forgot
because I've had like 20 MCU movies come
out in this span of time and really
those studio marketing problems end up
trickling down to creative itself sadly
the same looks to be the case for the
New Mutants a once-promising looking at
her themed x-men story which apparently
had to be reshot and now it's stuck in
development hell so to sum it all up the
timeline chronology goes first-class
Days of Future past x-men origins which
was erased
apocalypse Dark Phoenix x-men x2 the
last stand which was also erased the
Wolverine the Deadpool's Days of Future
past the future scenes of which were
also erased and Logan and if you're a
child in the future watching this video
who hasn't seen any of the x-men films
the ones worth watching first-class Days
of Future past x-men x2 the Wolverine
the Deadpool's in Logan and sure all the
amazing ones that Kevin Feige is
probably made by now comment down below
with your favorite x-men film and follow
me on instagram and twitter at EA vas
and subscribe to me rock stars for
breakdowns of everything Marvel related
thanks for joining me bye bye
[Music]